the boys fell through the ice on Bob's
Mill Lake
in Surly Hall on the afternoon of Sunday
the 11th of December
our deepest sympathies remain with the
families and friends of those involved
in this tragedy
we cannot comprehend the enormity of the
pain they must feel and our hearts go
out to them
we stand together with the local
communities in solihull and those across
the West Midlands and further afield but
we know were deeply affected by this
terrible tragedy
I would also like to take this
opportunity to pay tribute to all of
those who tried to save the boys
members of the public colleagues from
the emergency services and the doctors
and nurses from the children's hospital
and Parklands Hospital
my own local offices were the first to
arrive on the scene within minutes of
the initial call
and tried so desperately to rescue the
boys that afternoon with many wading
into Sub-Zero water up to their necks
to form a human change
they had no specialist equipment but
Gravely smashed their way through the
ice with their batons and Fists in a bid
to find the boys
sadly it wasn't long before they had to
make a difficult decision
to leave the freezing water
but their efforts didn't end there
they continue to help family members and
worried members of the public
I'm incredibly proud of those officers
who showed such bravery and put their
own safety to one side to try and save
the lives of Jack Tom Finn and Sam